hallo ich in meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen endlich zu einer
neuen folge der today show erwarten
stadt seit 1000 jahren auf simon
gespielt er heute gast ist und außerdem
auch den halo ungeheuer an ein gratis
getestet wo er hattest du die sachen wo
hättest du die kita oder auch wenn die
aus meiner kiste genommen gib mir bitte
die capitals wieder den rasen bessere
sachen als ich erfahren habe aus meiner
kiste geklauten bleibt wo ich auf euch
gewartet habe da hab ich da habe ich die
ganze scheiße du hast dir aus meiner
klasse
ich habe die letzte vollständige rand
sterben
die sache wieder man nicht alles okay
bei dem auch aufgenommen hat zurück so
ist jetzt gehen
seit ihren preis ich bin raus ich komme
aus dem feld heraus
hallo kinder
das ist vielleicht würde sich ja um den
öko image gerecht zu werden
beim auswerten baumhaus bauen aus rein
organischen mit materialien jetzt schon
gesagt vor die kamera liefert gesagt ich
möchte mir gerne ein haus bauen ja ein
baumhaus
ich bin dafür die brauchst du das hier
sowieso und dann brauchst du dir so
einen allein stehenden baum wo alles
drumherum abgeholt
ihren zweck also erstmal wir haben
überhaupt nicht richtig alles erzählt
wir haben direkt angefangen rum zu
schreiben
ja und zwar ist simon heute gast in der
talkshow wir wollen uns erst mal dafür
entschuldigen dass die letzte zeit
wieder so eine kleine pause war das war
einfach war halt so und wir hatten ein
paar leute gefragt und simon war
natürlich direkt vor ort hat sich direkt
bei uns gemeldet als denen ich bei
mcdonald's fahren da kann man dann auch
da rein geschnallt und mit currywurst
abgefragt haben sie doch widersinnig
alles bei einer currywurst ab das ist ja
alles bei der currywurst ab wo ich da
natürlich auch nicht auf einmal
verwandelt hat und dann diese currywurst
gegessen habe extra 400 kilometer bis zu
den eher hingefahren um die currywurst
zu essen und das bier alle tage eine
currywurst gibt es ja auch eine interne
für seine special muss man schon mal
ja okay gespielt
bla bla kann ich über gast werden dann
habe jetzt mal currywurst orchester muss
es dann direkt überlegt und dann haben
wir uns darauf geeinigt jahr könnten wir
theoretisch machen und deswegen ist er
sieht man jetzt die heute gast was mache
ich hier eigentlich
und wir haben natürlich der themen
rausgesucht und in zukunft wird es
natürlich wieder öfter theatershow
gegner regelmäßig ja genau wieder
spielraum
ich habe auch gesehen mit mit no drop
ich kann sachen für dich erfolg rang ach
ja und ich habe mir gedacht wenn wir
einen kleinen vorteil hier durch ein
paar sachen von kontrolle ist kann die
gäste aber nein natürlich dass jetzt
alles in meiner ändert es gibt kein
zurück
übrigens an meine zuschauer ich spiele
gerne ohne text gepäck in die hand
eigentlich auch aus dem grund
ganze teams geht
du hast alles was du brauchst du gar
nichts gehört
links ich spiele obwohl attack speck
ganz einfach aus dem grund weil ich gute
zwecks ein bisschen satt geworden bin
und ja hinsetzen warten bevor ich jetzt
ja anfangen und wo ihr habt doch auch
andere kiste wo ich auch sachen her
kriege oder von nicht vom letzten
spieler oder so jander axt und ich
brauch noch gewisse sachen halten
brauche ich finde das eigentlich haben
wir hier noch mal als dann aber hier ist
wieder alles lehren schwerte kannst du
da schwert hier ich hab dich einfach
sehr gut da kann ich mir eine man kann
ein zwei jahren machen
warum hast du schaufeln für mich
dasselbe eisen nein
hast du alle stücke für mich ist ich
spontan nicht im hause wollen wir
überhaupt erstmals zum thema machen hier
genau darunter das erste thema an alle
die sonne nicht mitbekommen haben wir
machen das jetzt immer alles direkt über
facebook das heißt uns auf facebook
einfach folgen licon etc
dann seid ihr immer auf dem neuesten
stand wenn wir aufnehmen und dann fragen
wir auch mal nach thema dann werdet ihr
erwähnt und et cetera pp und ihr wisst
glaube ich aus dann bedeutet es erst auf
die couch im rücken an rücken bisschen
fernsehen ich hol dir sagen der erstes
thema ist von kim henrichs ich geh mal
ein bisschen jahre mit software fx ja
wir nehmen auch mehrere thema in einer
folge dran wenn es so kurze themen sind
der den astag mit echten kraft ein video
aufklärung das können wir ganz kurzer
abhandeln für alle die es immer noch
nicht verstanden haben luca sowie hat
die kolbus geschmückt war das gut oder
also die currywurst an sich also ich bin
ja 400 kilometer dann als ich weil es in
der schule bis wann war mir noch mal bei
max
das war am donnerstag am donnerstag am
donnerstag wie viel uhr war das
ozeanografische seiner mittagspause also
so 13 uhr 13 uhr ja und zwar war ich da
erst bei mir zu hause bin ich ja noch
sechs uhr aufgestanden war dann erst bis
8 uhr in der schule hab dann gedacht da
kommen schon zigmal fahre ich mal mit
dem zug einfach so vier stunden fünf
stunden bis nach hamburg habe danach den
er getroffen
zufällig von einer currywurst essen
aufeinandergetroffen und hab mir dann so
gedacht ja könnten wir eigentlich damit
kommen haben eine currywurst gegessen
fand ich sogar eigentlich teuer aber
lecker eigentlich also es ging ja weil
die fiat kilometer waren hat das den
preis hochgetrieben hatte er 400
kilometer aber das passt natürlich wären
es witzig ist ja das was wir denn da
auch noch um gespielt hat erinnert wurde
auch über fünf kilometer entfernten ich
wohne in der nähe von conny und ja aber
für den dass wir kein weg zu weit sage
ich mal
wie läuft es eigentlich herum ja aber
ich brauche auch zu essen was zu essen
wir ja hier bekommst du essen würde ich
okay wir haben auch was für dich
was macht ihr da eigentlich gerade ihr
frage durch auch ich versucht zu
ergründen was einmal seite sind
ich hole mir erstmal ins haus von der
kef nach in hannover vergeben
kartoffeln leckerste luca
warum es aufdecken ja und zwar haben
mich alle nach dem video habe das gar
nicht richtig mitbekommen dass lena
dieses themas tag wieder hochgeladen hat
danach haben mich so immens viele leute
auf allen möglichen netzwerken
angeschrieben die teilweise nicht mehr
kannte war warum ich denn mich auf
einmal zeige warum ich denn die ganze
zeit sage ich zeige mich nicht und auf
einmal bin ich in den us den astag video
zu sehen et cetera blabla haben sie mich
hat alle angestellten ist dann gucke ich
mir dies den astag video anderen
willkommen in den austrag ich habe dann
können muss gegessen der donau und
blablabla setzen prioritäten fahren wir
mit dem besten thema an hier ich war mit
ich war bei majors mir schon sehr wohl
bin ich dann ja hallo hier bin ich geh
da hab ich mir nicht so viel bei gedacht
und dachte so dass die meisten leute das
irgendwie verstehen würden weil ich
dadurch schon oft gesagt habe dass ich
mich nicht so zeigen will et cetera
und da habe ich da nicht alle
angestrengt auch in den kommentaren rom
geschrieben und blase und ich denke hey
warum glauben dass alles war ich relativ
gereizt weiß mich ein bisschen aufgeregt
hat und die leute dann habe ich halt bei
facebook gepostet dass mich das ein
bisschen an passt warum das denn alle
vollidioten da glauben ich habe gesagt
ich zeige mich nicht das war nur ein
witz von dallas offen gehen
das war ein witz vom dna blabla und dann
kommt man natürlich wieder leute an und
ich werde immer noch angeschrieben sind
auf meinem zweiten kanal warum ich mich
denn gezeigt hätte leute das war ich
nicht
basta das war wie hieß der michael ich
habe glaube ich
was max michael mädchen war noch ein
anderes der auch im video
ach so ja da magst keine ahnung ok erst
macht euch mal überstanden hier ich habe
es dem geglaubt ich das für möglich
jetzt seid ihr keine freunde hat das
werk ok hab ich ein bett noch ruhig
schlafen kann hier im bett zusammen
romantisch schön wärs links schnell
gehört gut
also ich möchte jetzt mein haus folge
dinge haben parteien zusammen im bett
und dann meinte den es ging schnell
ja es ging halt wirklich sehr sehr
schnell gekommen
ich wollte den hangover aber gut kommen
ich brauche aber noch in einem truppen
häusling als ich in den dschungel
preisen tropenholz hat er ist oder was
vielleicht schaffen wir damit anzubieten
wir schauen noch mal kommen wir haben
aber auch einen dschungel
er wurde ja eigentlich dann ein
verfahren
ich kann ihn hinführen ende dafür gerade
schon er führt mich gerade
also haben ganz viele junge lehrer noch
nicht alle gefunden aber wir dachten wir
haben hier die wahl irgendwas gefunden
haben sie glaube ich nicht medien gar
keine kiste gehabt ich weiß aber wohl
dass ich nicht das ist erste ruine
das war toll hier
das nicht fertig gemacht haben mal nicht
schön gleich weiß kapitel rechtsverkehr
ist doch klar
da musst du wieder kandidiert aber
wieder keine ahnung was hier abgeht wie
ich habe keine hallo gittermast
die hot und die runde hier also diese
wiederum spielt einfach angefangen indem
ich einfach mal richtig rumschreit und
sterben tod ist ja schon pvp videos sein
können hier in dem ich in unserem
schreie und sterbe und tod bin also
irgend jemand war beim dschungel haben
wir eine junge links kandidat muss
richtung sowohl für anja da komm ich
habe mich so viel folgezeit muss das
beste haus überhaupt bauen alles so dick
sein auf meine idee die müssen ich hab
oder ein wo bist du der könig wenn mir
im haus den stopp aller weiter aus ich
weiß nicht ganz neu wird ein haus ist
das kam es auf seite ist auch in caracas
ist auch inspirierend ich kenne dieses
haus was unter diesen großen keller hat
und sogar das waren also das soll sein
haus science ist es kein haus aber ach
so aber sprechen nicht auf
regionalexpress und jetzt einfach nur
noch scheiße umgesattelt
wir haben alle fall wiederholen haus
abgebrannt wurde ja auch bei viera nicht
nachvollziehen
dann kommt für bis zum dschungel
wenn wir nicht sicher ob das jetzt
wirklich der richtige weg ist und ich
glaube dass sorgen vergab er verschwende
deine zeit camps gespendet will mir
nicht ich jetzt machen soll aber ich
weiß noch dass ich meine xp fantasien
und den bin ich nicht mehr nach hinten
aber ich glaube interessen junger erster
schock ich war gut ich musste mich auch
zum speichern ist schon dabei war ich
ein paar millionen franken muss zum job
ich hab' ich soviel ist schon etwas was
ich warum ist sie erstmals nicht muss
schon mal auf jeden fall was man braucht
auch schon mal musste datenbanken ab
mitnehmen sagt ich komme heim kommt das
ganze als die man in mittweida gespielt
und ich einfach mal rein
3 kommentare fehler entdeckt als er
nicht bereit der sondern bereiten
norwegisch du sagst parade denn ich hab
mich seiner aussprache wird und jetzt
sagt bereit bereit
nein das sei dann werde ich auch so du
musst dahin dahin ist im übrigen ist die
folge auch schon wieder vorbei das heißt
wir sehen uns dann bist du nichts machen
bis zur nächsten